all right
for those who've seen hackers
uh let's see if this goes it's not gonna
go
oh now use your best viruses to buy us
some time we have to get into plague's
file and copy the worm
all right there's a little tension
breaker that had to be done all right
okay
so attention breaker right uh i think
only a few you got that so
before we go any further i want to give
a uh
a very uh thank you to the organizers
of jsconf eu who believed
that security had a place at a developer
event
there is there was three talks about
security at a developer event and that
is
absolutely unheard of and i am very very
grateful for this opportunity
please everyone give a giant uh thank
you to
uh jan holger tiffany and mate
yes thank you so hey everyone i'm adam
uh as was said i am not a baldwin
brother uh you can find me on twitter
at adam underscore baldwin and a whole
bunch of other places
i'm evil packet on github and i'm the
chief security officer at and yet where
a lot of
these things that i'm going to talk
about have transpired
i get to work on some really cool things
like ann bang
taki.io and i'm also the team lead at
lift security
where i get to basically help developers
secure software
and build security into the culture of
their dev teams
i am also the founder and organizer of
the node security project
a rather an ex exciting and insane
experiment
to audit all of the things on npm which
there's like 40 000 modules now
and bridge the security and develo
and dev communities and try to make them
play nicely together and we'll talk
about that more later
so uh as it turns out when it comes to
security we're [ __ ]
right that's basically uh
that's it nothing is 100
secure this is this is a realization
that we have to come to
in building software there's going to be
bugs
we're going to inject security flaws uh
we are going to be
eventually at some point so
let's talk about risk
risk is a board game about world
domination
you spread out armies around the board
in a pursuit of conquering the entire
earth
it's very slow to move around uh armies
uh so
a typical strategy is to focus on uh
deploying new armies at uh
entry point or entry points for defense
and building up armies uh
when you're going to attack right in a
risk battle
you match dice one to one highest to
lowest and the attacker gets three dice
the defender gets two dice right there
you notice that the attacker has the
advantage
but the defender can only roll with as
many dice as they have armies
so when you only have one die left
you're rolling
one against three so the attacker has
broken through the outer boundary and
it's pretty easy to sweep through
and if iceland attacks uh greenland in
this scenario
uh which is totally prone to happen uh
greenland is going to get a roll with
two dice and it's
gonna be a pretty big battle but if
greenland only has
uh is the only only defends with one
army
uh in this scenario let's be honest
iceland is going to pone all of north
america
uh yes including alberta sorry alberta
uh and attackers have the advantage
uh attackers basically have the
advantage and that's it's it
it's akin to the way it works in
software too attackers have to find one
flaw
to get it gain a foothold and as
defenders
as developers we have to find and
address them all
it's a rather daunting and impossible
task
software's hard i don't think that
anybody is going to disagree with me
that building software is hard enough
without adding additional complexities
software's also full of uh opinions
we've got things like
mobile first right lots of first content
first
offline first woo
but a lot of what you build doesn't mean
crap if it's not built on
a foundation of security and privacy
which can
uh take all of the fun out of what
you're building
uh and software is full of constraints
right we've we've
we've got constraints like time and
money
uh a boss uh you know pointy haired boss
that's breathing down our neck to get
features ground out right
but security is one of those constraints
that that has to be filtered into that
sort of equation
so who's responsible for security anyone
want to take a guess
you are yeah
sorry but you need to be up to the
challenge right like
whether you like it or not you're the
first line of defense in addressing and
fixing security flaws
in the software you build you're the
ones building it so it's time to take
some responsibility
for this uh i was talking to the martin
before the talk and
as a developer if you if you don't care
about security but others care about
security in your organization or that
deal with that software
you're negating their effort a bit
uh security is not something that you
can just uh it's not a department that
that or a third party that takes care of
it for you
um and if it's the if that's the way
you're doing it you're doing it wrong
it's just not bolt on so why is it your
responsibility
well people like my wonderful family
there use
your software they use it for banking
transactions and social networks and you
know
all those private messages that we you
know send back and forth
you have a responsibility to handle
people's data
with respect and help
me as the consumer of your library or
your final product
that it's being done on how that
security
how you're treating that data with
respect many people
that use our software would would likely
be outraged by how
cavalier we handle some of some of their
data we owe them the respect
to handle that appropriately
last year or excuse me 2013 i think
that's right
the nsa spent 25 million dollars on
software vulnerabilities
they purchased o days and
vulnerabilities to
you know do their bidding
we have a responsibility as developers
to stay off of that menu
right we we should just
not be part of that procurement process
also litigation is coming we have uh
the ftc which is forcing a company
called trendnet who had a vulnerability
in some camera software
uh to suffer 20 years of auditing
we would love if somebody from the
government forced us
to have to audit our software right as
developers you would you would love that
right that'd be that'd be great
if we don't police and handle our
uh in our own community in our own
software
that external force is going to come
it's going to come eventually it's
happened in other industries
so it's just something to remember okay
so enough uh doom and gloom already
uh should we give up hell no we fight
back
we don't make this easy uh we don't give
in not every geek with a commodore 64
can hack into nasa
so something has to change right uh we
have to build a security first culture
we have to
we just have to we just have to do
better and the thing is is that sorry i
mentioned earlier
we're [ __ ] right well it's just it's a
constantly evolving process
we just need to take one step do better
iterate so
i'm going to tell you about the story of
and yet and how
i came to be at and yet and how we
handle security
at end yet basically how i
was a seed crystal in and yet and most
people know that a seed crystal will
produce beautiful results given the
right uh
environment and the right
sort of the right right growing
environment but it can't do its job
without that right environment
given you know even
best efforts so i met adam brault
at andiad about five years ago and i was
running a consultancy called ingenuity
and uh basically a single person
consultancy two two of us
and he was running a web development
shop and we realized very early on
that it was a very symbiotic
relationship
uh i could help him grow and build his
business
and it meant business from for for me as
well
it it sold contracts for him to have a
partnership with
with security showing that the level of
care that they took
in security for their software was the
difference between
many other very larger and
named vendors and so it started there
and so i would tell him about you know
hey you wrote this and you did this
you did this wrong right it's all
intensive purposes and so i taught him
so early on when it was him but as we
started to add people
i was still this external entity right
and so as he added people they write
code and i'd review it
and as we moved along their people
eventually started
learning hey we don't have cross-site
scripting
vulnerabilities as much as we re review
code
we've those have just sort of gone away
because we've we've
learned about that
and and as he grew from
you know one to two to ten to now say 23
people
uh at some point uh i sold ingenuity and
actually went to work friend yet
uh basically merged uh uh the security
practice in
right into the company and that's where
uh i had a really interesting
uh revelation i i'm part of the company
now
i can do more impact because i'm
internal right so secure all the things
i thought
and yeah it doesn't work like that you
can't just come in and say we're gonna
do this this this this this this
it just doesn't it it doesn't work like
that i really learned that uh
you have to take steps one at a time
and just iterate and do better and
increment or
for a short period of time you're going
to see you're going to see an
improvement but then it's going to it's
going to die
your your people are going to go back to
their old habits
and there's huge pushback to all the
things that i wanted to do
and we're still uh a couple years later
starting
continuing to implement on that initial
vision we've had and so it's been it's
been a slow iterating process
so the one interesting about education
um
which i'm going to go to this a little
bit later
um so why do we avoid during
during dirt
avoid security why do we avoid doing it
one why was i getting uh you know
pushback on securing all the things and
things like that
well one of the big things is uh
ignorance we don't know what we don't
know
we also don't like to have things
pointed out when we do them wrong
it's it's it's not a good it's not a
good feeling uh in any way
uh we also procrastinate uh it's it's
way easier to
procrastinate and put off this uh adding
those features because it's really cool
building the the new hotness right
rather than figuring out how to actually
secure the new hotness
it's not you know it's not particularly
exciting work uh and it's not rewarded
it's sort of the inverse we get we get
shamed when
something goes bad but if it's working
right and fine things just move along
it's not a problem until it's a problem
it's
there's a good analogy adam was telling
me about uh you know the
the people who produce the sound for
events like this
if my audio was just too cut out
and not work right uh or feedback or
whatever there's
quick blame to go to the sound to the
sound person but if it works flawlessly
it just works no one's going to go give
that guy a high five that
it worked great it doesn't so when it
when it goes wrong it just
it goes wrong um
it's just not glamorous so one way to
combat
ignorance is through education right we
need you know
we just need to sort of understand
vulnerabilities um
and this is where i welcome you to the
security community
uh please wipe your feet
so as we learn about the things that we
learn
we pass them on and just like that seed
crystal our community grows
um and uh when i talk to developers i
i often get asked about you know what is
the new scary [ __ ] what's
what's what does the security community
know that
that i don't know and that i should fix
in my app and
and i'm going to tell you
the simple stuff still works
it still works from years and years and
years and years ago
when we found these vulnerabilities and
the information has been out there
we continue to go along this mobius
strip
of development moving ahead and we we're
not learning from our past mistakes
we're just not doing it and there's some
other things there too
um
while i have you captive we're going to
sort of talk about a few things that
devs find
find scary let's talk about a few sort
of tangible things
i pulled my twitter feed and asked
developers uh
what they cared about security wise and
what they found
scary and difficult to implement
things that they thought that they were
going to screw up implementing
and those two things fell to the top
validation sanitization and crypto
right mike west already talked to you
about content injections so i'm not
going to do that and you know about the
the ways to uh validate and sanitize
your data you know
properly in content security policy and
those things and uh
uh martine talked about crypto a bit if
you want to learn
more uh i think you mentioned this the
modisano has a
as a crypto challenge uh where you can
learn about building crypto systems and
breaking them
i really recommend going through those
as a developer it will
level up your game quite a bit when it
comes to crypto
martine also suggested before the talk
that i mentioned the
courses on by dan
bona bon bone um
uh on crypto there's a there's a crypto
course uh it will
blow your mind but it's a short course
and it's worth it
so i'm not gonna talk about those things
i'm going to talk about something that
i'm a bit more familiar with that is
javascript related
it is not node conf i realize but it is
js related all the same
and it is npm we're using npm to install
a lot of things client-side code
um server-side code all
all the modules right there's 40 000
plus modules out there and the node
security project
is working on uh auditing those things
uh and that came
we started the project because we're
trying to secure a product
our product and bang it's built on node
and we were finding ways to compromise
the product we felt we had the
our code base really solid but we had
one interesting thing
we had we had code injection
a bunch of people in this room were
writing code
for our product right and they were
injecting it into our app and i was
you know basically trusting that that
code was
was good so i was looking for ways on
how i can inject code into other
developers
uh projects right how what what exists
for vulnerabilities there
so come along npm install coffeescript
is this right no this is not right it's
npm
installed coffee dash script and there's
a number of developers out there that
hate me for publishing that module
um so i actually took it down please
don't put it up please do not put it
back up
i'm mentioning this here and now because
this is a problem
we are a smart community everyone here
is
much smarter than i am in terms of
solving some of these problems we need
to
address this so what i did was i took
the top 100 modules and i did a typo
analysis
of those and then i did a passive
analysis on all the npm blogs which the
project was gracious enough to give me
so i didn't have to publish all of these
modules and see what happened
and a lot of things bubble to the
surface
package names with
punctuation dashes periods things like
that get misspelled way more often than
other things
but it's an interest it's a really
interesting attack surface it's a really
big problem
so uh when i published coffeescript
it got 200 installs roughly in about a
week and
it took that long to be discovered it
did nothing it was blank it had to read
me
um if i had mimicked the behavior of
copy script chances are
it would have taken a lot longer to to
be identified
so there there's my uh random scary [ __ ]
for the for the talk
so what else uh
process right so we go back to the
the hey we can't make
100 secure software uh it's gonna be a
process it's gonna exist and we're gonna
do it forever
um what you can't do though is you can't
just shove process down in the
face of developers and expect them to
abide by your
your law of security in your
organization it doesn't work
i tried to do that and yet and they
basically said
right um we don't we don't love strict
processes we work
in in much different ways and
i'm sort of being vague on some of this
because you need to find out what your
process is
for your team it's going to differ a lot
for each team
so uh let's see
one other thing is that we can take a
lit we can take a lesson from attackers
here
in that we have a really interesting
position inside of our organization
inside of our communities
and that's that's a position that
attackers would love to be in
insider threat you can sort of turn that
on its head right we're in a position
where we can
uh affect change we can actually
influence and uh
we can just change the process it's it's
not immutable it's like code
your habits are education they're
they're not mutable
we can change them um so
we need to um we need to do that
we need to take and change what you're
which how you're approaching things
uh and uh integrate security into every
basically every aspect of the
organization and and do so from
uh you know if management doesn't care
well uh
there's there's ways to uh help
influence that
just doing it and and just sort of take
over
um
community bridge all the world so i want
you to read
a blog post by adam brault it was
published a few uh
days ago uh from some discussions and in
topics uh that happened at nodeconf
and it talks about how to be a good
community uh member
in terms of other development
communities pointing and laughing and
shaming
we're uh we're really good at that in
the security
community we're really good at pointing
and laughing at
all of the code you write the things
that you do and
we uh you know we don't pull any punches
right we we basically
uh that's what we're good at and uh i
used to think of myself not as a
not as a dev and earlier this year so i
used to think of myself
just as a security person trying to help
developers
and i dropped out on the floor earlier i
dropped that trope earlier and said
okay i'm going to accept that i'm a
developer and i'm
that i belong in both communities i
dropped that trope and now i'm just a
bad dev
i'm just not like the code i write as
[ __ ]
but i'm embracing that role which as
soon as i embrace that role
i can get better i realize that this is
my responsibility
to learn how to do these things better
and i'm wondering if it's not time
for developers to drop the trope that
they aren't a little bit
uh security people or any other fringe
community that might be related to
development that
maybe you should be involved a little
bit more in that and say well
well i'm a bad security person i can get
better
um one thing and i realize why devs
don't join the security community is
because we can be very uh abrasive and
crass and
it's an unappealing place right we're
not necessarily that kind
but we can combat that come in numbers
you know it'll be good
the last thing that i want to plug uh
sort of out of the
out of the blue something random and
what i think that we all should do
is we should put security.md files in
our projects
it helps explain how you want
vulnerabilities disclosed in your
projects
it helps communicate the security
constraints
around your projects it tells how the
constraints in which your project was
designed
communicate the things about security in
this file
maybe it's just an email address i want
vulnerability disclosed here i want you
to tell me here
and give people a process if you want a
good example check out amber js's
they've got a fantastic disclosure
process it is a model for how we think
how we should be doing things
uh with uh with other javascript related
projects
so i've got homework if you've got
nothing
i want out of this at all do this
go to owasp look at the top 10.
learn about one type of vulnerability
i don't care what it is hopefully it's
something related to some
something that you're working on audit
some of your code
dig in if you don't understand it jump
into some security communities irc
channels
try to interact and learn about that
figure out how you can fix that
vulnerability and then teach somebody on
your team about what you did
just show them over lunch that's going
to take
you're going to be that seed crystal
that's going to start forming and
start changing this community
and i've got some homework for you now
because i'm going to finish up about
five minutes early
you've got some conf work to do i want
you to take
lunch as an opportunity to talk to each
other
about what you do in terms of security
some good questions are
how do you handle security on your
projects and if the answer is
uh i don't come talk to me or find
somebody else bring somebody else in and
talk about it
what's the vulnerability that you've had
in your code what's a bug that's
affected security and how have you
addressed it
tell those stories talk to each other
and that will have an immediate
and it will have a lasting impact on our
community
thank you
you